[موسيقى]
الان طبعا نشاهد خلف الملك تشارلز
الكرسي الذي يسمى
بكرسي القديس ادوارد كما قلنا في تتويج
سوف يرتدي
تاج القديس ادوارد او الملك ادوارد وسوف
يرتديها اليوم فقط
لمره واحده
مدى الحياه سهام وسوف يكون هناك ايضا تاج
للملكه القرينه وهو تاج الملكه ميري
وعندما ينزع تاج القديس ادوارد سيبتدي
التاج الامبراطوري وهذا ما جرت عليه
العاده راينا نرى الملك تشارلز الان وقد
نزع عباءه التشريفات التي دخل بها الى
كنيسه وست منستا
الشرف التي ستكون مناصرا شجاعا من اجل
نصره من يحتاجون اليك
امامه اسقف كانتربري كما راينا خلع الملك
عباءه التشريفات يجلس على كرسي القديس
ادوارد وسوف يقوم كبير الاساقفه بصب زيت
خاص من قاروره
ذهبيه وذلك
في ملعقه التتويج ويمسح به راس الملك
وصدره ويديه بعلامه الصليب ويتم استخدام
ملعقه التتويج وهي قديمه جدا
وقد نجت من عمليه تدمير
سابقه
وهذه المرحله الثالثه من مراحل
مراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز رسميا ملكا
لبريطانيا مراسم تتويج تتم عبر مراحل
مختلفه عثمان
تجري فيها تقاليد متوارثه في هذه العائله
ولكن ايضا كانت هناك ابعاد حديثه لهذه
التقاليد تم مخالفه التقليد من خلال مثلا
دعوه
اشخاص من العامه لحضور هذه المراسم وايضا
حضور
[موسيقى]